thank you
[Music]
and welcome back everybody to another
special episode of the careful boys
where we're currently right are we off
the Record we're off the Record always
yeah I love the confidence okay so just
some uh context I know this video is
going up a little bit later than some of
the fans have been asking in the
comments
um we're going to talk about the
Monterey Park and Alhambra shootings
today
um just for context when we shoot JK for
everybody who really really follows us
we shoot these uh segments every other
week and that shooting had happened on
the night of our last production shoot
that day so as everything all the news
was unfolding and stuff like that we
weren't going to get together until
today uh two weeks later to finally talk
was it happening simultaneously like
when you guys were eating the news came
up yeah well we didn't see the news
until after we went home after dinner I
was caught in the traffic from the road
closure due to that we were like a
couple blocks away from the incident
yeah and then when I got back and then I
was in my bed Ryan texted me and said
dude are you seeing this Monterey Park
shooting stuff and I'm like what and
then I started looking and it was only
like two live networks on YouTube and
some like people live streaming it and
it just happened and you sent us the
link in our text there of the guy who
was live streaming and and it was like
one of those things where as information
was getting you know pulled up it was
just reporting it in in live and that
wasn't even regular news I was literally
a guy live streaming because at 10 30
something we were still standing outside
on Valley kicking it so when it so would
[__] right when it happened we were
there like yeah we were just hanging
yeah after dinner that's crazy I was uh
we're celebrating Chinese New Year with
my mom and we were gonna eat around here
but then my mom's vegetarians were
looking for a dumplings in place because
she's really just wanted dumplings we
ended up being Fullerton and then I came
home I think they just went straight to
sleep but at like 8 A.M in the morning
on the news like I was like just like
brushing my teeth and that's what I
heard I'm like what the [__] are you
hiding here what the [__] I was watching
the football game I was in Vegas at my
neighbor's house just watching the
football game and then I hear because
his wife had local news on the other
room I hear Monterey Park shooting I was
like what the [__] because like that's
where we always got it and yeah
absolutely mind-blowing yeah that's
where this office is located yeah so
it's such a trip and it's crazy because
when it was all unfolding like while I
was watching the live I'm like these are
the streets we grew up on and like I was
there like I was at that intersection
yesterday or like you know it was like
that corner where everything went down
and I'm like what's going on and they
didn't even know like the full story yet
they didn't they knew that the the
gunman was on the loose they knew like
um there was something about like a
white van and they didn't know where
this person was so then uh everyone was
recommended to just like stay indoors
and have their uh doors locked and stuff
they didn't know the motive or anything
like that so I was like this is nuts and
there were people still out on the
streets like looking and trying to
record and I'm like
yeah I I just thought it was weird and
and like you hear all these stories
right and then like I think it's
different when you know the streets and
it's like home I could drive from memory
yeah yeah like that intersection I can
draw the whole thing from memory because
originally I thought everyone thought
that it was um they were having a
Chinese New Year event on the street you
know how they block off Garvey we did a
video there before yes we did a JK video
there
um but they some people thought that
there was a like mass shooting at a at
the Chinese New Year Festival timing
wise that's what it seemed like because
I know because it was I was eating
celebrating Chinese New Year with my mom
I know they block off uh Garvey Avenue
every single year so when you hear
shooting and you hear like the amount of
people uh that were hurt or injured
because they didn't know that if they're
dead just yet your first go-to thought
is oh this is a targeted attack yeah
that's your first goal and then the next
one after that they go oh it's actually
not the event they said that it was a
Chinese medicine shop that got shot up
and then like a couple people got hurt
and then so that was weird right yeah
and then they took that out and they
said oh it's actually the dancing and I
was like wait what but I remember
growing up we used to go to that place
it was a it was a pool hall it was a
pool hall and it was like riddled with
gangs like there was always shootings
there so I didn't so in my head it
wasn't that weird because I was like oh
yeah there is there was a shooting but
then
um it's no longer a pool hall it turned
into like a restaurant and then a dance
studio where old people do Cha-Cha so
then I was like wait why would there be
a shooting there that was the weirdest
thing no yeah I had a couple people uh
like outside of my immediate circle that
just heard like Monterey Park and dance
studio shooting so they were sending me
texts about it oh check-in yeah yeah
um and yeah it's just such a weird thing
to feel Associated or feel close to
something you know what I mean to the
point where people are like yo checking
like hey have you heard about this like
are you okay or like did anything happen
at your spot or whatever I had friends
that texted me too a lot of fans hit up
the the JK IG who know that we're in
Monterey Park and they were like are you
guys okay
like wow so a lot of uh you know I think
one a lot of crazy news like that like
hits the [__] public really fast a
lot of voices got you know out there a
lot of conspiracies got out there a lot
of misrepresentation got out there what
are some of the things that you guys
heard or or that like maybe caused a
little bit of friction in the
conversation of how this thing went
about because I know that people were
saying stuff like this is like another
Asian hate but it's like well that's
that's an old Asian guy or like this
must have been this because of that you
know what I mean you were bringing up
what's an old Asian guy the guy the
shooter all right they didn't know till
later yeah 72 year old agent right when
I was searching for the news like as it
was unfolding it was like there were so
many different things going on right and
then like I'm trying to get information
from like news sources but I'm going on
Twitter Instagram just searching on
Google
but then when I started seeing all of
people's like reactions unfolding
man people just made it about themselves
we just made it about like oh yeah me
being Asian and they want to talk about
how Monterey Park has the most Asians
and I'm like [__] not only have you
never been to Monterey Park I've never
seen you in this neighborhood you know
like and then you want to act like it's
yours like shut the [__] up like it's
not about you another thing is like all
the Asians that came out talking about
oh I bet it's a black dude oh I bet it's
white supremacy and it's like like how
do you how is that even how and then
like people wanted to debate about guns
and all that [__] and I'm all like it
hasn't even been like two hours since
the incident and you're already [__]
like causing all this stupid [__] but
the most annoying thing was about how
people made it about themselves dude and
their own personal agenda yeah and it's
it's like
what about the people that [__] died
and got hurt and all that like I don't
know that was the part I think that
pissed me off the most was seeing people
making about their own personal agendas
and then people with these loud voices
what kind of sucks is there are a bunch
of emerging heroes in the story that's
naturally built in yeah like the older
store owner who just came in and he was
like I heard gunshots I ran to the front
and then he his life ended up passing
because he he pretty much uh you know
like took one for the team then there's
the Brandon uh say guy who's like we see
videos of him wrestling which is a crazy
[__] video which is that video is so
nice like I shoot guns all the time yeah
I have a little bit of like combative
experience and I don't even know if I
would have jumped in you know for him to
just go oh [__] like just take initially
that's [__] crazy nobody knows if
they would do that no no oh dude the
other thing too is the way that he was
handling the old man like was so nice
yeah like that's what I was that was was
shocking to me because if I was like oh
this guy has a gun like I don't know I
might be so scared to the point where I
would murder him because he has a gun
yeah he took it away and he goes get out
of here yeah yeah like he was so like
still chill about it they were like
struggling for like it's not like a
minute dude that's a long time to be
fighting for something like that's the
guy who can comment on other videos and
go I would have done this
I did it but even but how many of those
are there dude the guys who say they
would are the guys who won't do it no
yeah even in all the interviews that I
saw that Brandon guy in it's like he's
really trying to retell his experience
and it feels so honest and he's not
trying to milk it he just like he's not
even trying to be a badass at all
like you know he just was like yo like I
didn't know if I was gonna actually
Deuce anything and I felt like I had to
but it was like you you it just feels so
honest and you're like man what a guy
dude you know it doesn't feel honest
when Biden calls him
yeah that was stupid but he's getting
you know what I do like about it though
is that he's actually getting the uh
props and notoriety that he should and
it's not being hijacked like from
another story I've never seen Biden more
racist than that phone call what
happened because he keeps emphasizing
yeah you're you're finally I mean you
are one of us you're one of us so I just
want to let you know you're you're a
mayor oh you're American
there was a lot of like weird breaks in
that yeah like his his Cadence was like
almost like he's falling asleep
[Laughter]
even I didn't even know who he was
talking to that's why I guarantee it
yeah but I just hope like one thing I do
hope is that this like Brandon seems
really like hey the aftermath of when
you do something like this is not what
you think
how he was like kind of saying like I
don't feel like a hero I just like he
was saying like there's like an anxiety
[__] yeah he's like I hope he gets like
the mental like there's PTSD for sure
for sure dude that's the main thing like
dude he did a good thing he's the man
you see you've seen Newsome uh went to
his house and [__] and then all the
Asian uh there's like photos of him at
Brandon's house right they're like
talking and [__] and then they circled
Newsome's shoes they're like this
[__] wearing shoes
Nikki was just showing me some video of
some guy and like standing somewhere and
I couldn't take my eyes off the fact
that he had his shoes on an area rug
yeah I was like this [__] did
anybody uh hear anything about like the
shooter or his motives or anything like
that
um I was getting kind of play-by-play
because I have a friend that works in
the police department so he gets like
the news maybe about an hour or two
um before it reaches like the TV station
so they told me he told me like the
white van I think it was found in
Torrance or something right and then
they said when they came up on it they
saw that the driver already passed away
um they think he took his own life or
whatever and then I think it's it's
tough because when you have situations
like this you're always trying to re
reverse engineer the motive you know is
it like a angry guy that's like his wife
cheated on him or like what's the reason
like you just don't know and then why
did he end up killing himself so it's
like I just you just get play-by-play
but I think till this day do we know
what the real I heard there's a there's
an update like the official update I
think is that he
um got kind of to ostracized from the
dance studios yeah and then so he wasn't
invited to something or whatever and
then so he's always been kind of weird
and aggressive and I think the dance
studio was his only like place of like
where he belonged yeah and then after a
while because of that
um it might have been like well [__]
these guys there is also like uh just in
that month prior um he went twice to the
police station in Hemet where he'd moved
into a trailer park and claimed his
family had defrauded and tried to poison
him
so like he's just got apparently this
paranoid world view of stuff you know
what I mean in general we had a friend
who uh whose aunt was uh one of the
people that had died
um they said that this guy was just
always really weird yeah he's just one
of those people like when you go to a
place and you're like something's wrong
with that dude you know but you don't
want to discriminate he's like the
school shooter that's just a senior
citizen honestly that's the vibe it's
like you know we don't want to like make
people feel bad or feel like ostracized
but there are some signs of like this
dude's not right yeah I mean he like 30
years prior he'd like uh he was taken to
jail for having a concealed weapon that
he didn't have like a license for or
something like that
um dude that was a crazy gun he got yeah
it didn't work they're not legal one
right it's actually a place like an Uzi
it was actually really rare was there
like a suppressor yeah it was like the
longest gun I've ever it's actually a
really rare because as soon as I heard
um they were talking about how it was an
assault pistol and I'm like uh oh my God
that's a new term dude I was like what
the [__] is an assault pistol that's my
friend and then they're like well
they're like technically it is because
it's like a Mac 10 right so it's like a
it's like nine Milli millimeter it is
technically a pistol but but no one in
the industry calls it that so they're
kind of like just throwing terms
together because they couldn't because
they it wasn't an assault rifle so they
couldn't say assault rifle but they want
to make it scary still yeah so they
throw another term together but then
that is has never been categorized in
the industry as an assault and that gun
is illegal you can't get that in
California is it a ghost gun oh but it's
illegal though you can't get it it's
like a Mac 10 with a suppressor there's
an automatic pistol you're saying no
amount of legislation would have
prevented him from happening but we need
a new law a new one well the thing the
thing that was pissing me off too is
like when I was watching the interview
in the morning with the police
department right so the police
department was trying to give accounts
and then this [__] journalist kept
going uh what was the what was the
caliber of the bullets uh was it an
assault rifle what kind of assault right
well and then after that term dude dude
he goes no it wasn't it was just a
handgun and they're like
yeah what sucks is that's the part that
muddies the actual solution because the
real like I guess illness and symptoms
we're trying to cure is the disgruntled
guy someone that got ostracized from a
dance studio his family
um like kicked him out he's living in a
trailer park like he's in he's down in
the dumps right it's the like classical
um anyone that's about to do something
drastic regardless if it's uh school
shooting or bombing or whatever like
these are the exact same symptoms so if
you can troubleshoot these symptoms and
catch people and help people get better
you'll prevent violence regardless of
how it matters right right but they're
so focused on this that will never fix
this and what's the this like gun
control and stuff control stuff because
you take take the guns away this
[__] will get in his white van
he'll just drive straight through the
studio same like we see this in every
other country Europe's Scandinavian
countries all these countries that have
really strict gun laws they not only
still have gun violence they have
stabbings and they have [__] uh
driving into people and so the more we
kind of focus on this fake Target we
never solve the like real problem but
why do you need an assault van
because they're fun I guess I don't know
that's why the um like when you look at
the root or when you look at the common
denominator of a lot of these people
there's a very big uh like a social
um abandonment and a paternal
abandonment and when you look at how
rare it is to see these in Asian
communities with Asian people
there's like look at this case this
guy's family is non-existent he has no
friends probably and so like in that
light of light it's not just a random
person who just happened to have a gun
it's like look at his life story yeah
like most most Asian people kind of have
a prioritized value with family health
yes and you kind of have this
accountability with each other and
you're less prone to do crazy [__] when
your family is in good health with
keeping tabs on you yeah this dude
didn't have that anymore nope that's why
there's nothing else to like feel weird
with yeah it is weird how like uh you
know growing up I remember any time
somebody did something like the combine
shooting and all that stuff every time
the news would get like talk about their
stories and I my reflex is always like
don't talk about their story right like
like like my reflex is always like I
don't want to know because it's almost
like it raises people to like be able to
do that to lash out and then everyone
finds out about them they become famous
for it yeah like there's more copies
yeah yeah but then when I you know as
I've grown older I realize like it is
important to try to get to the root of
these problems and I think that the
mentality of like we shouldn't try to
understand them at all is sort of like
the pre
um you know psychology like pre like um
learning about how serial killers minds
work instead of instead of trying to
just say we shouldn't talk to them at
all why would you want to talk to them
they're crazy yeah it's like you should
try to figure out what the [__] is going
on so we can help to find other ones but
also so we can try to solve the problem
because the patterns are kind of similar
right but at what point does somebody
understand a checklist of patterns where
they're like all right they have this
symptom this symptom this and I should
stop them before something happens like
what you know what I mean well well I
mean something is affecting you know men
over the age of 60 also with a high rate
of suicide also with the high rate of
like mental health and issues like we
talk about our [__] we don't do it as
good as maybe gen Z Millennials do talk
about it but Gen X and Boomers and and
they don't even understand the concept
or understand how to self-reflect or do
a lot of that stuff so then the older
generation especially like um in in you
know like the Asian Community too like
right after this shooting there was
another one a couple days after in in
[__] NorCal right yeah oh yeah the
farm and it's it was my uh my my my
friend knows the comp the those those uh
yeah the mushroom farm yeah it's a
mushroom Farms is a competitor of crazy
so I was like
back to back and especially like mass
shootings with in the Asian communities
it doesn't happen it happens to us it
happened to us but it doesn't happen
with a Asian shooter I guess and it
could just be around the Chinese Junior
where like your loneliness is kind of
like exaggerated now yeah slash groups
are like together as well yeah yeah yeah
and I understand that you can't
legislate people to become better
families so that they're just doing the
law has to do what they can where they
can affect it
but really the key for me is just you
take care of your own [__] people
yeah like the people one degree away
from you and if everybody did that a
little bit more you would definitely
have less this [__] yeah you know but
again like some people can be such
[__] that their family abandons them
that too you know or some people can be
such dicks that eventually they're
homeless and no one wants to care about
them yeah some people are that garbage
too but again the only responsibility
before it becomes society's job is
family yeah
I think what pisses me off the most
about all these situations all the time
is the conversations that are being had
are always it always comes off as
useless because one the media doesn't do
a great job they're just looking for
clicks they're just looking for like the
story right so if it's not like a white
guy coming into an Asian neighborhood
because white supremacy and like a mass
shooting then it doesn't make National
headlines right if it's like some if it
it has to have that like oh what's hot
right now you know what's really hot
race Wars is hot we gotta [__] do
that it's always hot you know what's hot
right now is using AR-15s so we need we
need the shooter to use that gun so we
could talk about it and then if it
doesn't hit those talking points that
they like and it's not that important
then they just won't do it yeah and then
they try to twist it they try to twist
it like they did with the assault pistol
and I'm like dude you're missing the
point now you want to talk about assault
pistols all [__] day and then it's
gonna continuously happen because we're
not not really getting to the root of
anything and the and the most boring
answer that doesn't make money for
anyone yeah is be better families yeah
yeah yeah that truly is an awful message
yeah for for monetizing right like
imagine titling this video that be
better if you don't have to buy anything
you're not it's you don't got to click
anything just be a better family that's
the person that gets his ass kicked in
the like NBC [__] writer's room
they're like race war title hate crimes
whatever what about be better family
you're [__] fine [__] up any money
because that's where it all begins right
because I remember right when I heard
about the shooting the narrative was was
like he was looking for his wife and he
it was it was like a big deal like he
was
like she was like cheating on him or
something so it was that story not even
true at all I found out later that his
ex-wife or something right
um it was his ex-wife they divorced yeah
yeah but that was even more of a juicier
story yeah that's what I mean like
that's what they kept saying though yeah
we should blame the shooter man your
story should have been more juicier
that's why you're not getting any
attention yeah get a better story dude
well when I heard he was a dancer I was
like that
you know because I'm laughing so hard
that confirmed some of my personal
biases yeah the people that were
checking on us were checking to see if
it was us
foreign